Dr Zakia next question is a very common
question and it's one that I'd like to
know the answer to as well it's um if
all the devils are chained during the
month of Ramadan how come people
continue to commit
sins and I do agree with you this is a
common question and I remember several
years back when I was in school and when
I heard this Hadith that the devils are
chin in the month of Ramadan immediately
the question that came to my mind and
the question that comes to many Muslims
mind and many non-muslims is that if the
devils are chained then how do people
how do human beings yet commit
sins this question is based on the
Hadith of MMI wasallam which I mentioned
earlier a had of mus
Ahmed volume number two page number 230
Hadith number
7,148 which is also repeated
in chapter number five Hadith number
21106 where the Beloved Prophet
said that o people the Blessed month of
Ramadan is approaching and Allah has
ordained for you that you fast in this
month and the Gates of Heaven will be
open in this month and the Gates of Hell
will be closed and the devils will be
chained in this month is a
night which is better than a thousand
months and a person who's deprived of
the blessing in this month is truly a
deprived person now when we give this
Hadith it clearly mentions that in this
month of Ramadan the Devils will be
Chained and a logical question if devils
are chained then how do human beings yet
commit
sins to make make the people understand
we have to realize that when the devils
are chained it does not mean that the
devils are slain they have been killed
they're yet present but they chained
they're not killed the power is it there
but it is diminished for a better
understanding I like to give you an
example that when there is a liion or a
tiger who is free there are high chances
that he may kill you your life in danger
but the moment that tiger or that lion
is Chained you are
safe you are safe as long as you
maintain a safe
distance after the Tiger has been
chained if you come too close to him
there are chances yet you can be killed
so as long as you maintain the distance
from the tiger who is Chained you are
safe similarly in the month of Ramadan
if you maintain a safe distance
from the Satan you'll be saved and if
you read the Quran Allah says in Surah
bakap 2 verse number 168 be careful of
the toan of the footsteps of the devil
for he is to you an a enemy many places
Allah subhana tala says in the Quran
that be careful of the footsteps of the
devil Allah doesn't say that be careful
of the devil because a normal Muslim an
average Muslim who has average Iman many
he sees the devil in front of him he
will be careful for
example suppose there's a young girl who
comes to an average Muslim a young boy
who has average Iman if a young girl
comes and tells him that let's spend the
night together that Muslim will say
spending the night together with a girl
is Haram it is z he will immediately
object but that same girl if that girl
owns that young boy and speaks to him on
the phone the boy will say speaking to a
girl on the phone there's no problem so
he speaks to the girl for a few times on
the phone for a few minutes later on the
girl says let's go and have some snacks
in McDonald's on Ki Fried Chicken having
snacks for a few minutes for half an
hour with a girl in McDonald's no
problem so he goes and has snacks with a
girl in McDonald's
later on the girl says why not have
dinner in a restaurant having dinner
with a girl in restaurant for a couple
of first no problem then the girl says
why not spend the night together and
then the boy says spending the night
together with the girl no problem so
this
is footsteps of the devil this is not
mentioned in the Quran this is just my
own example so what Allah warns us is
that be careful of
the the footsteps of the devil if the
Devil comes directly in front of an
average Muslim who has IM he will
abstain he will run away from it butan
are the things which are
dangerous so what we have to realize
when the devil is
Chained his footsteps are
restricted so many of the sins are
prevented but if we go close to him then
the chances that we'll be overtaken by
the devil and commit a sin are very high
so what we have to be careful that in
Ramadan if we keep the distance then the
chance of committing sin is less but if
we go close to the Satan even though
he's chained like how a tiger can walk
even after he's chained same the devil
so this is my understanding and the
beled prophet said the devils are chain
the devil canot move but less distance
so if we keep the distance we'll be safe
the second reason that I feel is that in
the month of Ramadan though the devils
are chained we fail to realize that the
balance 11 months they are free and the
impact that the devil has on the human
beings for these 11 months it leaves
those impact that impression in the
month of Ramadan to give a better
understanding I always give the
example that there are drug pedlers
which try and get customers the
youngsters from the colleges from the
universities so what they do initially
they give the drug free and they entice
the youngsters for having drugs later on
after some time they charge a nominal
amount for that drug later on they
charge an exorbitant amount but by the
time the youngster is already hooked on
to the
drug so even if the drug dealer is not
there they will try and find where the
drug dealer is they'll go out of the way
to find him and get the the drug and
many of them even if the drug pedler the
drug dealer is imprisoned by the law
they will go out of the way to find
someone else they may go in a chemist
shop and buy mandri whatever it is they
are so much hooked on to it so these
people who have become
addicts to drugs or rather say addicted
to the Satan even though the Satan is
imprisoned the effect is yet there so
this way we understand as a drug drug
dealer as a drug pedler even after he
goes the drug addict gets accustomed to
the drug so we human beings we
accustomed to the sin and even though
the Satan is imprisoned we keep on
committing these mistakes but mainly
those people who have become addicts
fall in this category so those who do
major sin fall in this category but the
normal Muslims the average Muslims who
haven't become addicted it's easy for
them to stay away from
sin and the third reason that I give
is that though there are some Scholars
who say that in this month of Ramadan
the strong Devils the Mars they
imprisoned the smaller ones are free so
they keep on committing mistakes but
Accord to my
understanding the third reason
is
that though the devils are chained by
Allah subhana wa ta'ala they can yet
whisper
and one of the ways the Devils try and
get the human beings close to them is by
whispering and Allah says in the Quran
in Sur Nas chapter number
114 verse number 1
to6 they whisper in the hearts of the
human beings and they withdraw among
them the Jin and Men it's talking about
the satans talking about the Devils who
whisper into the hearts of the human
being and the withraw and among these
devils are the Jin and the human beings
so maybe Allah subhana wa ta'ala has
impris the Devils who are the Gin but
the human beings V are yet free so one
category of devils that the Gins have
been imprison but the Satan are even
amongst the men that's what Allah
says who are yet free and yet we have to
be careful of The Whisper Of The Devil
the wasasa this wasasa mainly is thing
that attracts toward the sin the sin
they had committed but the chances are
less and furthermore it's clearly
mentioned the full Hadith that Allah has
ordained for you in this month of
Ramadan that you should
fast only if you fast according to me
will the devil's be imprisoned that's
talking about the Devils that are going
to attract you so Allah says if you fast
Allah has ordained for you fasting and
the Devils will be put in Chains so the
Devils that after you if you fast surely
they'll be restricted the criteria for
us to be away from the Devil is to fast
if you fast with the proper
Nia seeking the reward of Allah subhana
wa tala surely the devil will not be
able to entice you
and the best logical way to prove this
is if we check the crime rate
of the Muslim countries during Ramadan
it goes down but if you check the crime
rate of the non-muslim countries in
Ramadan it is the same the reason is
that because they are not fasting the
non-muslims this devil yet has an effect
on
them because the Muslims are fasting
if not all properly at least majority or
at least quite a large number so because
of that the crime rate in the Muslim
country then the month of Ramadan is low
as compared to the other months but the
crime rate in the non-muslim country is
approximately the same indicating
otherwise even the non-muslims they will
not commit any sins the criteria is that
you have to fast properly for the sake
of Allah subhana wa tala